POLICE OR FIRST RESPONDERS, 988
WILL CONNECT YOU WITH TRAINED
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS 24/7.
>>> ANDERSON, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I AM LAURA COATES, AND THIS IS
"CNN TONIGHT."
LISTEN, I WANT TO BE UP FRONT
WITH YOU.
WE'RE DOING SOMETHING DIFFERENT
TONIGHT, SOMETHING FRANKLY
THAT'S EXTREMELY DIFFICULT.
BUT WE TRULY BELIEVE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO DO.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S A TENDENCY TO
WANT TO TURN OUR EYES FROM WHAT
IS DIFFICULT, A TENDENCY TO JUST
WANT TO MOVE ON.
IT'S HUMAN NATURE.
I UNDERSTAND.
BELIEVE ME, I UNDERSTAND THAT.
AND SOMETIMES THE NEWS DOES
REQUIRE A SHIFT IN FOCUS.
BUT JUST BECAUSE THE CAMERAS
LEAVE A LOCATION DOESN'T MEAN
THE QUEST FOR INFORMATION HAS
ENDED OR THAT THE TRAUMA HAS
ENDED OR THAT IF WE SIMPLY CLOSE
OUR EYES THAT IT CAN'T HAPPEN OR
IT WON'T HAPPEN.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE PANDEMIC
OF GUN VIOLENCE AND THE
INDISCRIMINATE NATURE OF MASS
SHOOTINGS.
NONE OF US WANT IT TO EVER
HAPPEN AGAIN.
BUT THE "IT" IS COMPLEX.
IT'S VERY MULTIFACETED.
AND HOW DO WE GET THERE TO WHERE
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN WITHOUT
FULL TRANSPARENCY, WITHOUT
STAYING ON THE STORY?
WELL, WE -- WE CAN'T.
THAT'S WHY TONIGHT WE'RE GOING
TO BE PLAYING THE FULL 77-MINUTE
SURVEILLANCE VIDEO FROM THE
UVALDE SCHOOL MASSACRE IN
REALTIME.
YOU MIGHT BE ASKING WHY WE'RE
DOING THIS.
THREE REASONS.
FIRST AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
BECAUSE THE FAMILIES OF THE 19
BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN AND THOSE TWO
BRAVE TEACHERS WHO WERE KILLED
ON MAY 24th, THEY DESERVE
ANSWERS.
THE SURVIVORS DESERVE ANSWERS.
THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY DESERVES
ANSWERS.
AND WE CAN'T PUT THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS TO THE POLICE WHO
RESPONDED OR THE LOCAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS UNTIL WE CONFRONT
HEAD-ON EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
AND THE SECOND REASON WHY, WE
KNOW THAT YOU'VE SEEN PARTS OF
THIS AGONIZING VIDEO, MAYBE
30-SECOND CLIPS HERE, MAYBE A
MINUTE HERE, THE BITS WITH THE
MOST ACTION, SO TO SPEAK.
BUT IT IS ACTUALLY THE LACK OF
ACTION THAT SPEAKS VOLUMES ABOUT
THEIR RESPONSE.
MINUTES PASSED, AN ENTIRE HOUR,
AND NOTHING HAPPENS.
AND I'M LEFT WONDERING, YOU'RE
LEFT WONDERING HOW AND WHY, AND
WHAT DOES IT REALLY MEAN?
AND THAT LEADS TO OUR THIRD
REASON TO PLAY IT.
TO HELP IMPROVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S RESPONSE
NATIONWIDE TO MASS SHOOTINGS
GOING FORWARD BECAUSE WE ALL
KNOW IT'S A SAD TRUTH THAT A
SHOOTER MIGHT TARGET A SCHOOL
AGAIN.
COLUMBINE, VIRGINIA TECH, SANDY
HOOKE, PARKLAND, AND NOW UVALDE.
AND THERE MAY BE MORE.
SO, WHAT CAN POLICE LEARN FROM
WHAT HAPPENED HERE?
AND TO WRESTLE WITH THOSE
QUESTIONS AND MUCH MORE, I'M
JOINED BY CRIME CORRESPONDENT
SHIMON PROKUPECZ, WHO HAS BEEN
ON THE GROUND IN UVALDE SINCE
THIS HAPPENED.
HE'S JOINING US HERE TODAY.
AND TWO CNN LAW ENFORCEMENT
ANALYSTS, FORMER FBI DIRECTOR
ANDREW McCABE AND FORMER
PHILADELPHIA POLICE COMMISSIONER
CHARLES RAM SEE.
NOW, SOMETIMES WE'RE GOING TO BE
TALKING AS THE VIDEO IS PLAYING
AND GIVING REPORTING AND CONTEXT
AND ANALYSIS.
AND SOMETIMES WE'RE GOING TO BE
SILENT JUST TO LISTEN TO WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
BUT HERE'S AN OVERVIEW OF WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE.
AND I -- PLEASE DON'T LOOK AWAY.
WE'LL SEE THE GUNMAN ENTER THE
SCHOOL.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE IN REAL
TIME, MINUTE BY MINUTE HOW
HEAVILY ARMED AND SOME HEAVILY
SHIELDED OFFICERS SPENT ALL THAT
TIME OUTSIDE THE DOOR TO THOSE
ADJOINING CLASSROOMS.
YOU SHOULD ALSO PREPARE YOURSELF
BECAUSE WE WILL PLAY THE SOUNDS
OF THE GUNSHOTS RINGING OUT.
NOW, THAT HAS NOT BEEN PLAYED ON
CNN BEFORE.
WE INITIALLY DIDN'T AIR THE
AUDIO OF THE GUNMAN FIRING OUT
OF RESPECT FOR THE VICTIMS'
FAMILIES, AND WE STILL MAINTAIN
THAT RESPECT.
IT'S INCREDIBLY PAINFUL FOR THEM
AND THE LAST THING THAT I OR
ANYBODY WOULD EVER WANT TO DO IS
TO COMPOUND THEIR GRIEF.
BUT THE VIDEO, WHICH WAS
OBTAINED BY "THE AUSTIN AMERICAN
STATESMAN" WAS PUBLISHED IN FULL
ON THE PAPER'S WEBSITE SEVERAL
DAYS AGO.
AND BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN IN THE
PUBLIC SPHERE, BECAUSE THE
OFFICERS' RESPONSE WAS INFORMED
BY THE GUNFIRE, WE ARE CHOOSING
TO LEAVE IT IN FOR A FULL AND
ACCURATE ACCOUNTING OF WHAT
HAPPENED.
NOW, HERE'S WHAT YOU WILL NOT
SEE AND YOU WILL NOT HEAR.
YOU WILL NOT HEAR THE CHILDREN
SCREAMING.
THAT WAS EDITED OUT BY "THE
AUSTIN AMERICAN STATESMAN"
BECAUSE IT'S TOO GRAPHIC.
CAN YOU THINK OF ANYTHING MORE
PAINFUL TO HEAR.
BUT WHILE WE WON'T HEAR THOSE
PAINFUL SOUNDS, REMEMBER THE
OFFICERS, THE OFFICERS THERE,
THEY COULD HEAR.
THERE WAS NO EDITING OUT OF THAT
MOMENT.
YOU WON'T SEE THE FACE OF A
CHILD WHO WAS WALKING IN THE
HALL WHEN THE GUNMAN ENTERED WHO
THEN TURNED AND RAN AWAY.
THE STUDENT'S FACE WAS BLURRED
TO PROTECT HIS IDENTITY.
WE'RE GOING TO PLAY THAT VIDEO
IN JUST A MOMENT.
BUT FIRST I WANT TO GO AROUND
THE TABLE AND ASK EACH OF OUR
ESTEEMED PANELISTS, WHO ARE THE
RIGHT PEOPLE TO HAVE THIS
DISCUSSION ON A NIGHT LIKE THIS.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT IS THE ONE
THING THAT YOU WANT OUR VIEWERS
TO KEEP IN MIND OVER THE NEXT
ONE HOUR AND 17 MINUTES.
THERE WERE SEVERAL MINUTES, AS
YOU ALL KNOW, IN THINKING ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON, I'M WONDERING
FROM EACH OF YOU, WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO LOOK FOR?
AND WE ALL KNOW HOW DIFFICULT
THIS IS FOR THE AUDIENCE, FOR
THE VIEWERS, FOR THE FAMILIES,
AND THE NECESSITY OF HAVING TO
REALLY BE IN THIS MOMENT AND
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HELP
EXPLAIN THE INEXPLICABLE,
FRANKLY.
BUT WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO BE
LOOKING FOR?
SHIMON, YOU HAVE BEEN ON THE
GROUND.
YOU HAVE BEEN -- BY THE WAY, YOU
HAVE BEEN UNBELIEVABLY CRUCIAL.
I HOPE YOU UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS
NOT TAKEN LIGHTLY, THAT WE KNOW
HOW DIFFICULT IT IS.
AND FOR YOU TO BE THERE DAY IN
AND DAY OUT, YOU ARE AN ALLY,
AND YOU HAVE BEEN SO
PROFESSIONAL.
AND YOU HAVE BEEN DEVOTED, WHICH
IS WHAT WE KNEW YOU WOULD BE.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THANK YOU,
LAURA.
AND, YOU KNOW, THE SUPPORT FROM
CERTAINLY THE NETWORK HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLE.
YOU KNOW, BEING THERE, JUST FROM
THE FIRST MINUTES THAT I GOT
THERE ON THE GROUND, I KNEW
SOMETHING JUST DIDN'T MAKE
SENSE.
THE TIMELINE DIDN'T MAKE SENSE.
A LOT OF THINGS WE WEREN'T
GETTING ANSWERS TO JUST DIDN'T
MAKE SENSE.
AND THEN LOOKING AT THIS
VIDEO -- AND THE MORE I LOOK AT
THIS VIDEO, FOR ME THE THING IS
THE FIRST MOMENTS OF THIS.
THE MINUTE THE OFFICERS -- YES,
THE GUNMAN GETS INTO THE SCHOOL,
AND HE'S IN THERE FOR A LONG
TIME.
AND HE GETS IN THERE SO EASILY.
HE'S JUST ABLE TO WALK RIGHT IN.
AND HE'S IN THERE FOR SO LONG,
AND THE OFFICERS THOSE FIRST FEW
MINUTES WHEN THEY GET INSIDE AND
WHAT WE SEE THERE AND THEN
RETREATING.
THAT, TO ME, HAS BEEN ONE OF THE
MOST PAINFUL THINGS TO SEE, AND
IT'S BEEN ONE OF THE MOST
CRUCIAL THINGS TO SEE BECAUSE
RIGHT THERE SORT OF GET THIS
FEELING THAT THEY JUST GAVE UP.
THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO, AND
THEY GAVE UP.
>> WHAT DO YOU GUYS THINK?
YOU ARE, IN LAW ENFORCEMENT,
UNFORTUNATELY YOU HAVE SEEN MORE
THAN MOST PEOPLE WILL EVER SEE
IN A LIFETIME COMBINED
EXPONENTIALLY.
WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING FOR,
COMMISSIONER RAMSEY?
>> WELL, I THINK THE ONE THING
THE PUBLIC OUGHT TO KNOW IS THE
ACTIONS OF THE OFFICERS REALLY
AREN'T CONSISTENT WITH ACTIVE
SHOOTER TRAINING.
DON'T THINK THIS IS WHAT IS
BEING TRAINED THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY BECAUSE IT'S NOT.
THE FIRST FEW MINUTES OF THE
OFFICERS AFTER THEY ARRIVE, WHAT
THEY DO IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
TRAINING.
BUT AFTER THAT, THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TAKING PLACE.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE TO KEEP THAT IN MIND THAT
THAT IS NOT A REFLECTION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IT JUST ISN'T.
>> ANDY?
>> LAURA, THERE ARE SO MANY
NOTES.
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS, AS YOU
GO THROUGH THE TORTURE OF
WATCHING THIS ENTIRE VIDEO,
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS THAT
JUMP OUT TO PEOPLE LIKE
COMMISSIONER RAMSEY AND I.
BUT THE THING THAT STUNS ME IS
WE SHOULDN'T EVEN BE GETTING TO
THAT.
IT'S ALL SUPERFLUOUS.
THE BIGGEST MISTAKES WERE MADE
IN THE FIRST THREE TO FIVE
MINUTES.
NONE OF WHAT FOLLOWS SHOULD HAVE
HAPPENED IF THE INITIAL RESPONSE
HAD BEEN CONSISTENT WITH ACTIVE
SHOOTER TRAINING AND THE ENTRY
HAD BEEN MADE AT THAT POINT.
IT'S TOUGH TO WATCH.
>> WE'RE GOING TO WATCH IT AND
WE'RE GOING TO HONE IN ON THOSE
POINTS BECAUSE THERE WERE
SEVERAL MINUTES CAPTURED ON
VIDEO BEFORE THE GUNMAN EVEN
ENTERED THE SCHOOL.
SURVEILLANCE CAMERA SHOWS HIM
CRASHING A TRUCK JUST OUTSIDE
THE PROPERTY AND FIRING AT TWO
PEOPLE WHO WERE APPROACHING HIM
WHO QUICKLY RAN FOR COVER AND
WHO, THANKFULLY, ARE OKAY.
THEN CROSSING THE PARKING LOT OF
ROBB ELEMENTARY SCHOOL, WHEN THE
SHOOTER STARTED SPRAYING BULLETS
OUTSIDE THE SCHOOL, A TEACHER
CALLED 911 WHILE SHOUTING AT
CHILDREN TO TAKE SHELTER INSIDE
THEIR CLASSROOMS.
AND HERE WAS THAT FRANTIC CALL.
>> I CAN'T SEE HIM.
I CANNOT SEE HIM!
NO.
HE'S SHOOTING.
I CAN'T SAY ANYTHING OVER THE
INTERCOM.
THE KIDS ARE RUNNING.
OH, MY GOD.
[ SOUND OF GUNFIRE ]
GET IN THE ROOM!
GET IN YOUR ROOM!
[ SOUND OF GUNFIRE ]
>> AND THEN AT 11:33 A.M. LOCAL
TIME IN UVALDE, TEXAS, THE
GUNMAN ENTERS ROBB ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL
.
[ SOUND OF GUNFIRE ]
>>> WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A SHORT
BREAK NOW, BUT WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP THE VIDEO AND THE CLOCK
RUNNING.
AND FOR FULL TRANSPARENCY, I
WILL DESCRIBE WHAT HAPPENED IN
THOSE FEW MINUTES THAT WENT BY
WHILE WE ARE IN BREAK.
REMEMBER, THIS IS 77 MINUTES IN
ALL.
THINK ABOUT THAT AS WE GO INTO A
BREAK.
THOSE MOMENTS THAT YOU AREN'T
SEEING, THOSE POLICE OFFICERS,
THEY'RE STILL IN THAT HALLWAY.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.